Nun können wir wieder
ganz normal aufbauen.
Der Tumor, mit dem du
Probleme hattest, ist weg.
Nun machen wir nur noch Nach-
kontrollen, damit nichts nachwächst.
Es sieht wirklich gut aus.
Super, nicht wahr?
Das wird ein schöner Sommer.
Jetzt bist du müde.
Aber einen grossen Sprung
haben wir gemacht.
Gehen wir das feiern?
Geht ihr feiern!
Genau.
Du kannst den Kuchen ...
Willst du ihn abdecken?
Du kannst ihn rausnehmen.
Was steht drauf, Silvan?
Die Chemo hat genervt.
Das ist die Familie
meiner jüngsten Schwester Irmela.
Sie ist freischaffende Hebamme,
Wolfgang ist Physiklehrer.
Lisa, Maurus und Flurin
gehen in die Volksschule,
Silvan, der Jüngste,
in den Kindergarten.
Eine ganz normale,
chaotische Familie.
Die Krebsdiagnose
hat schlagartig alles verändert.
Die Krankheit bringt
die ganze Familie durcheinander,
auch mich als Tante.
Wir reden viel und beschliessen,
dass ich sie mit der Kamera
auf diesem unbekannten Weg begleite.
Eine Gratwanderung.
Was machen wir,
wenn es ihm plötzlich schlecht geht?
Aber wir sind überzeugt,
dass es uns und anderen helfen kann,
über die Krankheit zu reden.
Hallo zusammen!
Das Drama begann im August 2011.
Bei Silvan fand man
einen grossen Tumor an der Niere.
Wir wussten noch nicht,
wie bösartig dieser ist.
Dabei hatte Silvan zuerst
nur ein bisschen Bauchweh.
Wir waren in den Ferien.
Wir waren zu weit weg vom Arzt.
Ich wollte wissen,
ob er Probleme
mit dem Blinddarm hat.
Wir gingen zum Kinderarzt.
Der wusste auch nicht, was los ist.
Er schickte uns weiter
zum Notfall im Wallis.
Sie sagten: "Wo wohnen Sie?
Gehen Sie ins Kinderspital!"
Ich hatte es
immer noch nicht realisiert.
Ich dachte, in einer Woche
oder ein paar Tagen.
Ah, heute, heute Abend.
Dann merkte ich: Aha, jetzt ...
Für jede Behandlung
wie z.B. Blutentnahme,
bekommt Silvan eine Perle -
auch für die Chemotherapie.
Was ist denn die Chemo?
Weisst du das?
Ja.
Sag es mal!
Äh ...
So kleine Männchen, die helfen,
gegen den Krebs zu kämpfen.
Grüezi.
Ich komme noch mal
wegen der Narkose-Besprechung.
Ich habe Vanille, Schokolade,
Erdbeere und Orange.
Was magst du am liebsten?
Schokolade.
Am nächsten Tag wird er operiert.
Das findet Silvan v.a. spannend.
Die Angst der Eltern
spürt der 5-Jährige noch nicht.
Es ist alles möglich.
Es könnte gut kommen
oder auch nicht.
80 % ist so eine Zahl ...
Es geht gut.
Das ist viel schöner als 20 %,
aber 100 % wäre besser.
Irgendwie halten wir uns
an diesen 80 % fest.
Was die anderen 20 % sind,
wissen wir nicht so genau.
Wir nehmen es,
wie es kommt und hoffen.
Hoffnung - ein strapaziertes Wort
wird plötzlich so gegenwärtig.
Und die Sehnsucht
nach einer guten Prognose
drängt sich
ins Leben der ganzen Familie.
Nebst der Diagnose
war der schlimmste Moment der,
als er es mir sagte.
Ich bekam die Diagnose.
Okay, Silvan hat einen Tumor.
Aber ich habe noch 3 Kinder.
Ich war irgendwie gespalten
und dachte: "Mein, Gott ..."
"Wie packe ich das?"
Ja.
Die beiden haben 4 Kinder.
Ich besuche
Silvans 3 Geschwister zu Hause.
Meine Nichte und die beiden Neffen
müssen damit leben,
dass ihre Eltern
sich im Moment intensiv
um den jüngsten Bruder kümmern.
Silvans Krankheit
betrifft die ganze Familie.
Auch Lisa, Flurin und Maurus
sind in diesen Strudel des Tumors
hineingezogen worden,
versuchen jedoch,
den Alltag zu leben.
Der 9-jährige Flurin
muss schon jetzt tapfer sein.
Ich hätte gern eine Katze gehabt.
Sie ist schon auf der Welt.
Aber es geht nicht,
wenn er Chemo hat.
Nun müssen wir halt
noch etwas warten.
Warst du wütend?
Ja.
Wieso bist du denn eifersüchtig?
Weil er halt ...
... mehr darf.
Er bekommt jede Woche
etwa 2 Geschenke oder so,
von irgendjemandem.
Er hat soeben
einen Piraten bekommen.
So einen Bärenpiraten.
Oder solche Sachen.
Schwierig, oder?
Ja.
Er hat manchmal das Gefühl,
er komme zu kurz - jetzt erst recht.
Ich habe das Gefühl, in letzter Zeit
nervt Flurin viel mehr.
Hast du das Gefühl,
das hat etwas damit zu tun?
Ich weiss es nicht.
Mama ist ziemlich müde.
Und dann nervt sie sich schneller.
Das regt ihn auch auf.
Lisa ist 14
und die älteste der Geschwister.
Im Moment konzentriert sie sich
auf die Kantiprüfung.
Das lenkt sie ab von den Sorgen,
sagt sie.
Ich bin zuerst
schon ziemlich erschrocken,
als er sagte, es sei ein Tumor.
Aber er sagte,
dass es gute Heilungschancen gäbe.
Man könne Chemo machen, operieren,
und dann sei es wieder wie vorher.
Mein Grossvater hatte auch
einen Tumor und ist dann gestorben.
Darum bin ich zuerst erschrocken.
Der 12-jährige Maurus liebt es,
auf dem Wasser zu sein.
Er spürt, dass die Eltern anders sind
als vor Silvans Krankheit.
Wenn ich darüber nachdenke,
es kam schon manchmal vor,
dass ich das Gefühl hatte,
das sei sozusagen wegen Silvan,
dass sie etwas verschlossen
oder ruhig sind. Aber ...
... so direkt berührt es mich ...
Also ich merke es einfach.
Ich frage mich dann: "Wieso?"
Und dann ist wieder gut.
Wie reagierst du, wenn du merkst,
dass er Zeit braucht?
Also, so richtig konkret
nervt er mich,
wenn er Papa braucht, obwohl ich
Zeit mit ihnen verbringen möchte.
Ich merke es eigentlich nicht.
Eher so im Nachhinein:
Ah, Silvan braucht sehr viel Zeit.
Verstehst du es auch ein wenig?
Ja.
Hast du manchmal auch Angst,
dass er sterben könnte?
Ich denke, wie es ohne ihn wäre.
Schon ab und zu, aber nicht oft.
Der Tag der Operation
im Kinderspital Zürich.
Irmela und Wolfgang
sind seit dem frühen Morgen hier.
Sie trauen sich nicht, das Spital
zu verlassen, obwohl sie wissen,
dass die Operation
noch ein paar Stunden dauern wird.
Wir dürfen mit der Kamera
im Operationssaal dabei sein.
Meine Schwester sagt,
sie finde es schön,
wenn ich als Tante
wenigstens in Silvans Nähe sei.
Ich bekomme weiche Knie, als ich ihn
so liegen sehe, den kleinen Wicht.
Aber mir hilft es auch,
dabei zu sein.
Kaum zu glauben,
dass in dem kleinen Körper
ein so grosser Tumor gewachsen ist.
Die befallene Niere
muss auch entfernt werden.
Es sind lange 5 Std.
im Operationssaal.
So, guten Tag!
Grüezi!
Die Operation ist vorbei.
Sie verlief sehr gut.
Wir konnten die Niere,
wie es sich gehört, entfernen.
Auch die Lymphknoten, die in der
Nähe waren, konnten wir rausnehmen.
Wir wussten, dass sie gross
und auch befallen sind.
Und beim Tumor, ist da alles weg?
Kann man das so sagen?
Also was man sagen kann:
Von Auge gesehen ...
Knoten und Knollen
haben wir entfernt.
Aber das ist oft keine
auf zellulärer Basis
vollständige Entfernung.
Das ist häufig nicht der Fall.
Das ist einer der Gründe,
wieso man ohnehin noch mal
eine Chemotherapie machen
und vielleicht noch
eine andere Therapie anhängen muss.
Das müssen die Onkologen sagen.
Aber es ist definitiv so,
dass nicht irgendwie ...
Chirurgisch ist es sauber.
Wir haben einen wichtigen,
weiteren Schritt gemacht.
Bis später.
Adieu!
Auf Wiedersehen!
In etwa 30 Min.
können Sie zu ihm gehen.
Okay.
Auch diese halbe Stunde geht vorbei.
Ja, ja.
Vielen Dank.
Und?
Schön.
Ein Schritt.
Super!
Aber schon erleichtert, oder?
Ja, chirurgisch gut und zellulär ...
... muss man schauen.
Das ist der nächste Schritt.
Ja, ja, aber jetzt ist gut.
Was hast du gestern gesagt?
Wie machst du es?
Von Tag zu Tag.
Hallo, Flurin.
Wir haben den Bericht bekommen,
dass ...
Rumpeln
Hast du den Lautsprecher drin?
Wir haben den Bericht bekommen,
dass alles gut gegangen ist.
Sie konnten die Niere entfernen.
Und ...
Du musst nicht so genau ...
... vom Auge gesehen
sieht alles gut aus.
Silvan ist wieder zugenäht.
Es ist nichts Unerwartetes passiert.
So weit ist alles gut.
Ich wollte euch kurz anrufen,
damit ihr das wisst
und gut in die Schule kommt.
Mama, ich mag nicht mehr.
Ich knuddle dich ein bisschen.
Es geht ja.
Leises Wimmern
Willst du raus?
Meine Schwester ist Tag und Nacht
bei ihrem jüngsten Kind.
Im Kinderspital geht das.
Sie sagt, es sei, als ob sie
in einer Art Blase leben würde -
die Welt draussen weit weg.
Wer will klopfen?
Die Geschwister besuchen nicht nur
den Bruder, sondern auch ihre Mama.
Die fehlt ihnen.
Oh, du bist aber gross.
Hallo zusammen.
Hallo, Lisa.
Jetzt gibt es noch ein Geschenk.
Als Max das Bein gebrochen hat,
bekam er auch ein Geschenk.
Meins.
Du brauchst noch eine Schere.
Nein, nein!
Au, nein!
Bist du ein Vampir?
Bist du immer noch
ein Vampir wie gestern?
Das Spital ist ganz Vampir.
Hey, Silvan, bist du wahnsinnig?
Schau mal!
Noch wissen wir alle nicht, dass sie
noch viele, viele Tage und Nächte
im Spital verbringen werden.
Ein paar Wochen später
trüben dunkle Wolken die Hoffnung.
Der Krebs
ist viel aggressiver als vermutet.
Meine Schwester ist fix und fertig.
Es ist weiss und blau.
Aber Silvan freut sich,
wenn wir mit der Kamera kommen.
Auf meine Frage, wie es ihm geht,
diktiert er seiner Mutter
diesen Zettel.
Was machst du jetzt mit dem Zettel?
Ich nehme ihn überallhin mit,
ausser, wenn ich zu Hause bin,
dann habe ich ihn nicht immer dabei.
Aber wenn du weg gehst,
hast du ihn im Rucksack?
Ja.
Wir haben unterdessen
14-mal bestrahlt,
also 14 Sitzungen
und gleichzeitig Chemo.
Und wie viele müsst ihr insgesamt?
Es sind 12 Chemo-Blöcke,
3 davon haben wir hinter uns.
D.h., immer wieder
für jeweils 3 Tage ins Kinderspital.
Ja, also, er macht ...
Er war letzte Woche in der Chemo.
Er macht es wirklich super.
Tschüss!
Viel Spass!
Damit sie wissen,
was mit ihrem Bruder während
der Chemotherapie jeweils passiert,
sind sie heute
an den Geschwisternachmittag
im Kinderspital eingeladen.
Nun gehen sie mal ohne uns
ins Spital. Das ist super.
Ja.
Wir dürfen zu Hause bleiben.
Bist du froh?
Ja.
Ich auch.
Verbringen wir
einen schönen Nachmittag? Ja.
Die 3 Grossen sind jetzt
öfters als sonst auf sich gestellt.
Silvans Krankheit
beeinflusst auch  i h r  Leben.
Nun ist er oft weg
und hat Mama bei sich.
Wie ist das für dich, Flurin?
Es geht. Maurus
findet es manchmal gut.
Wieso?
Keine Ahnung.
Stimmt das?
Dass Mama mit Silvan weg ist?
Das ist mir eigentlich
mehr oder weniger egal.
Was mich nervt, bist du.
Was war denn anders?
Sie waren nicht so oft weg.
Maurus:
Sie hatten mehr Zeit für dich, oder?
Ja, ja.
Untereinander reden sie kaum
über die Krankheit ihres Bruders.
Aber ab und zu kommen
vor dem Einschlafen ein paar Tränen.
Wolfgang ist so oft wie möglich
bei den Kindern.
Er hat ein Teilzeitpensum als Lehrer
und wird von seiner Schule
mit viel Verständnis
von Nebenaufgaben entlastet.
Silvan ist sehr lebendig.
Er ist eine Rakete. Ich weiss nicht,
woher er die Energie hat.
Wir sitzen abends alle so am Tisch.
Lisa meinte:
"Mama, wird der nie müde?"
Dann hat er sich 3 Tage
im Spital erholt.
Nicht wahr?
Ja.
Dir gehts gut. Jetzt ist Mama müde.
Ja, es ist v.a., wenn wir jeweils
vom Spital nach Hause kommen.
Letztes Wochenende sind wir
am Samstagmorgen heimgekommen.
Ich habe dann
extra Gipfeli mitgebracht.
Es war ein gemütliches Morgenessen.
Abends wurde dann gestritten.
Alle waren müde
und hatten doch ihre Bedürfnisse.
Das ist wahnsinnig anstrengend.
Ich denke, es wäre so schön
und gemütlich, alle sitzen am Tisch.
Es ist einfach ein Riesenchaos.
Dann lassen alle ihre Gefühle los.
Genau.
Sie streiten dann
ziemlich untereinander.
Du darfst schon kommen,
wenn du willst. Willst du zu Mama?
Kommst du zu mir?
Du kannst auch zuhören.
Es geht ja um dich.
Papa hat schon den Apéro gemacht.
Jetzt ist sie nicht mehr so streng,
oder?
Ja.
Und im Spital
bekomme ich immer Nutella.
Nutella?
Ja.
Das gibt es zu Hause
nur in den Ferien.
Isst du das sonst viel in den Ferien?
Ja.
Das finden die Geschwister
manchmal nicht so toll.
Was passiert denn
mit den Geschwistern?
Sie wollen auch immer das,
was ich will.
Kannst du das verstehen?
Ja.
Was macht ihr dann?
Das geht ja nicht immer.
Ich mache das, was sie wollen.
Machst du ihnen
manchmal auch einen Gefallen?
Ja.
Ich bringe Nutella mit.
Flurins Rezept ist backen.
Seinen Schokoladenkuchen
kennen schon fast alle
auf der Krebsabteilung
im Kinderspital.
Silvan habe ich auch schon mal
einen Kuchen mitgebracht.
Hat er sich gefreut?
Ja.
Gehst du ihn manchmal besuchen?
Flurin findet es nicht erwähnenswert,
aber ich weiss,
dass er, wenn möglich,
jeden Tag nach der Schule
zu seinem kleinen Bruder nach Zürich
ins Spital fährt - ganz alleine.
Einmal in der Woche geht Flurin
mit seinem Freund zur Trommelprobe.
Das hilft ihm,
seine manchmal auftauchende Wut
ein bisschen zu kanalisieren.
Flurin hat seiner Trommellehrerin
sofort davon erzählt,
dass sein Bruder Krebs hat.
Dann machen wir Pause.
Rhythmisches Trommeln
Ich habe das schon gespürt,
dass er etwas sucht,
etwas Anerkennung
oder was auch immer.
Ich finde, es ist mein Job, dass sie
Freude haben an dem, was sie tun.
Sie sollen
die Begeisterung behalten,
und er kann einfach so sein,
wie er ist.
Wenn er mal etwas übermütig ist,
soll er so sein.
Dann lösen wir das mit dem Böckchen.
Dort kann er sich abreagieren.
Aber er soll einfach so sein,
wie er ist.
Es ist ein Raum, der ihm gehört,
den er nicht mit anderen
Geschwistern teilen muss.
Wieder einmal
müssen Silvan und seine Mama
für die Chemotherapie
3 Tage auf den Planeten Onko,
wie sie es im Kinderspital nennen.
Silvan ist frustriert.
Der Tumor ist weg, und immer nach
der Chemo fühlt er sich schlecht.
Das versteht er nicht.
Hör zu,
soll ich noch eine Suppe machen?
Oder willst du die vom Spital?
Ich mache sie mal warm.
Also, ich gehe mal in die Küche,
gell?
Ich gehe mal in die Küche.
Es kostet dich viele Nerven.
Du sprichst ihn an und sprichst ihn
an, aber er reagiert nicht.
Ich könnte eigentlich gehen,
aber das wäre nicht gut.
Er will schon, dass ich da bin.
Sagt er das?
Wenn ich sage, ich gehe,
sagt er Nein.
Am Anfang konnte ich zu ihm ins Bett
liegen und döste vor mich hin.
Aber jetzt sagt er:
"Geh aus meinem Bett!"
Und ich: "Okay."
Wieso schläfst du immer hier?
Ich glaube, es ist für ihn
so eine Scheiss-Situation.
Und da finde ich ...
Es ist für ihn
eine Ausnahmesituation.
Und er muss so stark sein,
um überhaupt hier zu sein
und das Ganze
über sich ergehen zu lassen.
Nachts muss er ständig aufs WC.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist ...
Entferntes Rufen
Okay, er ruft.
Musst du aufs WC?
Warst du diese Woche im Kindergarten?
Jetzt gehts in die Garage.
Wenn du den wirfst, geht er kaputt.
Den hat sicher schon mal
ein Kind herumgeworfen.
Es sieht so aus, als wäre er
schon mal etwas krank gewesen.
Und der?
Der ist heute auch extra gekommen.
Woher ist der denn?
Silvan murmelt vor sich  hin.
Mama!
Nein!
Ich will einen Film.
Silvan, nein!
"Nur für Schwimmer ist der Steg.
Du da, Kleiner, scher die weg!"
"Euch zu erziehen,
ist meine Pflicht."
"Im Wasser mampfen, sicher nicht,
und lass dir eines sagen:
Schwimme nie mit vollem ..."
... Magen.
"Die Badegäste rasten aus.
He, Besserwisser, geh nach Haus!"
Die Nächte sind lang im Kinderspital.
Wenn Irmela nicht schlafen kann,
surft sie im Internet.
Dabei hat sie
die Homepage von Malin gefunden.
Malin ist ein Mädchen,
dessen Bruder an Krebs gestorben ist.
Sie schreiben sich oft.
An einem Sonntag beschliessen wir,
Malin und ihre Familie kennenzulernen
und fahren zu ihnen.
Die Geschwister wollen mitkommen.
Es war eigentlich
eine relativ spontane Sache.
Ich dachte schon bei der Hinfahrt:
"Oh, es ist schon speziell,
dass wir dorthin gehen."
Wir sagten klar, dass das
die Geschichte dieser Familie ist.
Wir wissen nicht, was wir
für eine Geschichte haben werden.
Ein halbes Jahr leben sie nun schon
mit ihrer Geschichte
von Silvans Krankheit und sind froh,
dass sie sich
mit jemandem austauschen können,
der Ähnliches erlebt hat.
Natürlich hat Flurin wieder gebacken.
Kommt rein!
Malin ist 10 Jahre alt und hat
jahrelang vergeblich Kinder gesucht,
die wie sie
ein krankes Geschwister haben.
Ihr Bruder Till hatte einen Hirntumor
und musste auch während 4 Jahren
immer wieder zur Chemo
ins Kinderspital.
Nun ist es ein Jahr her,
seit Till gestorben ist.
Es ist erstaunlich,
dass Silvans Geschwister
trotz dieser traurigen Geschichte
mitgekommen sind.
Sie sagten nicht,
dass sie nicht mitkommen wollen?
Nein, sie sind total interessiert.
Sie sind neugierig.
Malin hatte Angst,
dass sie nicht kommen wollen.
Nein, nein, niemand muss.
Wir sind halt
ein schlechtes Beispiel.
Nein, das ist für sie nicht ...
Sie sind auch im Kinderspital
fasziniert.
Für Flurin ist es schon hart.
Er sieht ja auch, wenn ein Kind
wieder einen Rückfall hat.
Flurin stand neben mir,
und ein Vater sagte im Gang zu mir:
"Unser Kind hatte einen Rückfall.
Wir haben praktisch keine Chance."
Dann gingen wir im Gang herum,
und er schaute ins Zimmer rein
und sagte:
"Mama, muss dieses Kind sterben?"
Ich sagte: "Du, ich weiss es nicht,
vielleicht hat es noch eine Chance."
"Aber es hat weniger Chancen
als Silvan."
Das hat ihn tagelang beschäftigt.
Sie spielte die ganzen 4 Jahre
mit ihren Playmobil-Männchen.
Die Playmobil-Männchen
seien eine Onko-Geschwistergruppe.
Kinderstimme im Fernsehen
Silvan hat sicher auch
manchmal einen solchen Ständer.
Im Spital, diesen Ständer.
Ja, der Tannenbaum.
Er steht drauf und wir ziehen ihn.
Auf den Tannenbaum?
Er steht so drauf.
Berührende Musik
Er ist am Einschlafen.
Und der andere daneben ist wach.
Ich mache Turnübungen.
Wer hat gedrückt?
Oh, nein, du spulst.
Ah, du machst Zeitlupe. Lustig.
Berührende Musik
Hat er nur Fussball gespielt, oder
hat er noch etwas andres gemacht?
Er, nein.
Als er gesund war,
spielte er Fussball,
nachher spielte er
Playstation-Fussball.
Überall Fussball.
Das ist er.
So geil.
Hatte er schon immer eine Glatze?
Nein, das ist von der Chemo.
Er hat aber mehr Haare als Silvan.
Weil ich so neidisch war
auf diese Ketten,
hat mein Mami auch für alles,
was ich hätte tun sollen,
diese Dinger gekauft.
Ich habe auch so lange Ketten.
Voll cool!
Schau, er hat ganz andere Dinger
dran als Silvan!
Die Orangen hat Silvan nicht.
Doch, vielleicht noch nicht.
Die mit den Punkten
hat er auch nicht.
Doch, die hat er.
Was ist das? Weisst du das?
Das ist die grosse Blutentnahme.
Das weiss ich.
Wirklich?
Gelbe hat er auch viele.
Das ist "bestrahlen".
Echt?
Diese Plättchen.
Ah, ja, jeden Tag hat er 2.
Ein paar Wochen später.
Im Nachhinein ist es super -
einfach super.
Wir haben wirklich ...
Sie können miteinander chatten,
wenn sie Sorgen haben.
Sie können Malin schreiben.
Sie versteht sie.
Sie fragen auch nach.
Ich habe wirklich
einen super Kontakt zu Kerstin,
zur Grossmutter ...
Wir haben einen regen Austausch.
Es tut allen gut.
Ich weiss nicht,
es ist keine Seelenverwandtschaft,
aber es sind irgendwie
gleiche Geschichten, die verbinden.
Wir wissen etwas von ihnen,
und man fühlt sich schneller
verstanden - auf irgendeine Art.
Es ist, als ob wir uns
schon ewig kennen würden,
in ganz kurzer Zeit.
Sanfte Musik
Zwischendurch
geht es planmässig schlecht.
Wir wissen jetzt nicht mehr
als im Herbst.
Im Moment können wir nichts messen.
Man sieht nichts.
In 5 Jahren wissen wir dann
eigentlich, was ist.
Aber diese 5 Jahre,
als Mathematiker weiss ich,
das ist die Zahl der Statistiker.
Medizinisch
hat diese Zahl keine Bedeutung.
Gehen wir wieder nach Hause?
Ziemlich anstrengend.
Magst du noch?
Ich weiss nicht.
Wir fahren
nicht mehr lange aufwärts.
Ich habe den Eindruck,
er ist in einer anderen Welt.
Tod und "für immer" ist für ihn
noch ein abstraktes Konzept,
das er irgendwie
anders auffasst als wir.
Er ist noch im Indianerleben-Spiel.
Bum, Bum, und dann ist man tot.
Es ist kühl geworden, oder?
Gibst du Gas?
Ja.
Ich habe das Gefühl,
wir würden nichts anders machen,
wenn wir wüssten, es wäre anders.
Wir müssen schauen, Silvan ...
Er darf trotzdem
in den Kindergarten, wenn er möchte.
Im Moment mag er nicht.
Dann ist er halt mit uns zu Hause.
Wir geniessen es so oder so.
Und die anderen 3 Kinder?
Ich glaube, es gelingt ganz gut,
auch mit den anderen 3 Kindern
immer wieder etwas zu unternehmen.
Es ist ein Thema,
um auch an die anderen zu denken.
Man hat es schnell mal gelesen.
Auch von verschiedenen Leuten
oder von Kollegen in der Schule
oder Nachbarn
werden wir darauf angesprochen:
"Was ist
mit den anderen Geschwistern?"
Lisa, die Älteste,
packt es mit Ehrgeiz.
Ich begleite sie heute
in die Kletterhalle.
Hier verbringt sie jede freie Minute.
Ich klettere sehr gern.
Und nun kenne ich dadurch
viele Leute.
Fast ein bisschen wie eine Familie.
Ja.
Du bist natürlich auch gut.
Lisa ist das einzige Mädchen
in der Gruppe der sog. Hardrocker.
Auch 7 Monate nach der Diagnose
hat sie noch niemandem hier erzählt,
dass ihr Bruder Krebs hat.
Okay, Lisa, super. Weiter so!
Jawohl, super!
Wenn du runterfällst, ist das egal.
Die anderen freuen sich sicher,
wenn wir wieder nach Hause kommen.
Manchmal sind die Blutwerte
von Silvan so schlecht,
dass Irmela und der Kleine
vom Kinderspital
wieder nach Hause geschickt werden.
D.h., die Chemotherapie
wird verschoben.
Wie reagieren die anderen,
wenn ihr wieder hier seid,
bei solchen Planänderungen?
Ich glaube, sie finden es toll,
lieber so, als wenn wir
plötzlich weg wären.
Wie geht es den anderen im Moment?
Es ist sehr unterschiedlich.
Ich verstehe manchmal nicht,
was los ist,
ob sie dem Alter entsprechend
einfach motzen
oder ob es wegen Silvan ist.
Flurin ist immer noch im Stress.
Er denkt: "Ah, Silvan
bekommt immer so viel."
Es ist so schwierig.
Mal geht es so gut,
dann wieder schlecht.
Gestern stritten wir wieder
wegen dem ins Bett gehen.
Sie merken,
dass ich vorher ziemlich nervös bin.
Bevor du ins Kinderspital musst?
Ja, das merke ich selber.
Dann bin ich ziemlich gestresst.
Bis ich mein Zeug parat habe ...
Ich muss die ganze Woche managen.
Wie geht es dir und Wolfgang?
Sehr gut.
Vorher war es stressiger,
als ich viel gearbeitet habe.
Und jetzt bin ich mehr zu Hause,
und wir haben dasselbe Projekt.
Gestern war die Grossmutter hier,
und wir gingen allein zum Rhein.
Dann machen wir mehr ...
Alle Leute wollen helfen.
Wir sagen: "Super, kommt! Wir machen
uns einen schönen Nachmittag."
Das ist eure grösste Hilfe?
Ja, das ist im Moment sehr gut.
Der 12. April: Silvan ist heute
6 Jahre alt geworden.
Alle:
# Happy birthday to you.
Kommt ihr an den Tisch?
Singt ihr auch?
# Happy birthday to you.
Obwohl er in den letzten Wochen fast
nie mehr in den Kindergarten ging,
weil er sich zu schwach fühlte,
sind seine Gspänli gekommen.
Wow, bravo!
Jubeln
Hast du dir etwas gewünscht, Silvan?
Aber etwas Gutes.
Super, was?
Verrat ich nicht.
Was wollt ihr trinken?
Es gibt Sirup, Süssmost und Rivella.
Alle:  Rivella.
Ehrensache,
dass Flurin den Kuchen gebacken hat.
Am Morgen
war Silvan in der Kontrolle.
Irmela will mir kurz erzählen,
wie es war.
Als er hörte, dass das MRI gut ist,
ist er quasi ...
Er sagte: "Hey, ich bin ja gesund."
Und er fragt trotzdem ...
Heute sass er auf dem WC und fragte:
"Kann ich Willi wieder bekommen,
wenn ich ihn einmal hatte?"
Ich sagte: "Man weiss es nicht
so genau. Es kann schon sein."
"Es ist nicht sicher. Jetzt
ist er weg. Wir wissen es nicht."
Was sagte er?
Er sagte: "Hm."
Er hätte gern gehabt,
wenn ich Nein gesagt hätte.
Das konnte ich nicht.
Dann merke ich schon ...
Oder am Abend ...
Er spricht jeden Abend von seinem
Grossvater, der gestorben ist.
Dann merke ich schon ...
Sanfte Musik
Der Kindergeburtstag mit Schatzsuche
und allem Drum und Dran
ist in vollem Gange.
So habe ich ein bisschen Zeit
mit Lisa alleine.
Wie gehts dir eigentlich?
Gut.
Oh, es raucht.
Noch etwas Kleinere.
Hattest du manchmal Angst,
er könnte sterben?
Am Anfang ...
Als mir Papa sagte, dass er Krebs
hat, bin ich schon erschrocken.
Ich fragte,
wie es mit den Chancen aussehe.
Er sagte, dass es ziemlich gute
Heilungschancen gibt.
Daher dachte ich nie ...
Aber ich denke nicht, dass ...
Was denkst du nicht?
Dass er einen Rückfall hat?
Nein, also ich hoffe nicht.
Klar, das hofft niemand.
Legst du deins auch noch drauf?
Oder hast du schon?
Nein, ich habe es noch in der Hand.
Nun könnten sie kommen.
Du gibst dir aber Mühe.
Kindergeschrei
Habt ihr meinen Schatz geklaut?
Alle:  Nein!
Da, schau! Da oder da.
Da sind wir jetzt. Das stimmt schon.
Dort müsste er sein.
Gehen wir mal dort hoch!
Ja, das ist er.
Lisa:
Wow!
Achtung!
Schwer.
Wenn ich darüber nachdenke,
es ist auch heikel.
Es ist viel von unserer Familie,
es ist unsere Geschichte.
Im Kinderspital sehe ich andere
Familien, andere Geschichten.
Es ist wichtig,
dass man darüber spricht.
Es ist irgendwie
doch ein Tabuthema.
Nicht alle gehen gleich damit um.
Es gibt Familien,
die das mehr unter sich ausmachen.
Wir gehen halt sehr nach aussen.
Ich habe das Gefühl, es ist auch
wichtig, dass man das thematisiert.
Warum?
Weil man sonst als Familie
ziemlich abgekapselt ist.
Die Leute haben eine Hemmschwelle,
weil sie sich nicht trauen,
zu fragen, oder weil sie
nicht wissen, wie es ist.
Wir hätten noch eine Tour
machen können, aber es ist gut so.
Aber das sind schon Momente,
in denen man es vergisst, oder?
Ja.
Die Stiefel ausziehen?
Ja, gern.
Gute Nachrichten
helfen in diesen Zeiten.
Die Freude ist gross.
Kerstin, die Mutter von Malin,
ist wieder schwanger.
Diesmal besuche ich sie alleine.
Die Geschwister von Silvan waren in
der Zwischenzeit schon mehrmals da.
Bei der Vorsorgeuntersuchung
haben sie gesehen,
dass es ein Mädchen wird.
Wir haben uns keine Gedanken
darüber gemacht, was wir möchten.
Es braucht so viel Mut,
das überhaupt zu wagen.
Als wir es erfahren haben,
dachten wir, dass es gut so ist.
Und Malin fand,
dass es für sie einfacher ist,
wenn sie einen Bruder im Himmel
und eine Schwester hier hat.
Niemand hat
an eine Schwester gedacht.
Das gab es noch nie.
Ich glaube auch,
es ist gut für das Kind, das kommt.
Wir hätten es
ja nicht extra verglichen.
Aber trotzdem: Eine Schwester gab es
noch nie, und das ist fair für alle.
Hallo.
Malin war schon der Motor.
Ich glaube, ohne Malin
hätten wir es nie nochmals gewagt.
Nochmals daran zu glauben,
dass es auch gut kommen kann,
hätten wir 2 Alten
ohne Motor nicht noch mal gewagt.
Das ist eigentlich Tills Zimmer.
Aber sie braucht ja am Anfang
nicht unbedingt ein grosses Zimmer.
Und am Anfang
ist es einfach etwas ...
Es hat Sachen von ihm und von ihr.
Und nachher ...
Das ist z.B. von ihm.
Das sind aber alles Kleider ...
... für sie.
Und hier ist ein kleines Bettchen.
Was hast du gesagt,
als Mami erzählt hat,
dass du ein Geschwisterchen bekommst?
Ich glaube,
ich habe angefangen zu weinen.
Ich weiss es nicht mehr.
Aus lauter Freude wahrscheinlich.
Ja.
10 Monate nach der Krebsdiagnose
von Silvan
hat seine Schwester Lisa
die Gymiprüfung bestanden.
Seine Brüder Maurus und Flurin
waren erfolgreich
an den Kanu-Schweizermeisterschaften
und Silvan hat heute
die letzte Chemo hinter sich.
Das alles wollen sie feiern und haben
Kerstin und Malin dazu eingeladen.
Und wir sind ein letztes Mal
mit der Kamera da.
Alle reden durcheinander.
Willst du es versorgen?
Weg mit dem Zeug!
Flurin ist glücklich. Den Grund dafür
will er Malin unbedingt zeigen.
Das ist die Kleine.
Jö!
Wann bekommst du sie?
In etwa 5 bis 6 Wochen,
vielleicht auch vorher.
Wieso hast du sie
nicht vorher bekommen?
Wegen Silvan.
Sie schaut immer so lieb.
Freust du dich?
Ja.
Wieso wolltest du unbedingt
eine Katze?
Ich finde sie einfach süss.
Es ist mein Lieblingstier.
Fast zur gleichen Zeit,
wenn du eine Katze bekommst,
bekomme ich ein Geschwisterchen.
Wann? In den Schulferien?
Ja.
Diese Geschichte zu filmen,
war für uns alle eine Gratwanderung.
Wir wünschen, dass es vielleicht
anderen Geschwistern, Eltern,
Tanten oder Göttis hilft,
über das Schlimme zu reden
und nicht zu verzweifeln.
Und dass es Mut macht, nachzufragen,
auch bei den Geschwistern -
immer wieder.
Eigentlich fast alle,
die wissen, was passiert ist,
fragen: "Wie gehts Silvan?"
Ich sage dann immer:
"Ja, es geht im gut."
Was soll ich sonst sagen?
Ich weiss auch nicht mehr.
Er lebt.
Das war im letzten Juni.
Was wir in diesem Moment
nicht wussten:
Nach den Sommerferien kam der Krebs
zurück - schlimmer als zuvor.
Wieder eine grosse Operation
und heftige Chemotherapien
und Bestrahlungen folgten.
Doch es kamen auch gute Nachrichten:
Heute geht es Silvan gut.
Es bleiben die Hoffnung und die Angst
vor jeder nächsten Kontrolle,
aber auch die Freude
über jeden geschenkten Tag.